bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de tv
60,18 c'est l'essentiel de l'actualité
locale en quelques minutes nous sommes
le mardi 2 mars voici les titres de
cette édition
après deux semaines de prolongement des
soldes d'hiver se termine ce soir une
édition mitigé en raison de la crise
sanitaire et de la fermeture des grands
centres commerciaux
mais certains sites comme mot clé
souvent on tirait tout de même leur
épingle du jeu qu'en est il des magasins
et centre-ville est la pige à de l'union
des commerçants et artisans de maurepas
est notre invité cette année encore la
clinique des franciscaines à versailles
a été reconnu pour la chirurgie du dos
elle est placé en première position du
palmarès du point dans cette spécialité
créée en 2010 le centre francilien du
dos regroupe sept chirurgiens nous avons
pu découvrir son activité
enfin un reportage au musée maurice
denis de saint germain en laye il vient
de prêter l'une de ses 5000 oeuvres pour
une exposition entre cleveland et
portland aux états unis le lieu a pour
habitude exporter ses collections dans
le monde antique
avant de développer ces titres un
épisode de pollution aux particules
fines est en cours en ce moment en ile
de france avec une qualité de l'air très
mauvais sur une grande partie de la
région et notamment vous le voyez dans
le nord des yvelines le seuil
d'information a été dépassé ce mardi
indique airparif l'organisme chargé de
la surveillance de la qualité de l'air
en ile-de-france est la pollution qui
devrait durer au moins 24 heures
favorisée par les températures du jour
et l'absence de vent en conséquence la
préfecture de région compte deux régions
conseil de différer ses déplacements
routiers de privilégier les transports
en commun elle recommande de réduire sa
vitesse de 20 km/heure sur les
autoroutes routes nationales et
départementales
ce mardi soir marque la fin des soldes
d'hiver la période avait été allongée de
deux semaines pour compenser le
couvre-feu à 18 heures alors même si les
soldes ont été plus que mitigé au niveau
national avec la fermeture des grands
centres commerciaux
le bilan est plutôt bon localement est
parfois bon localement comme dans ce
centre commercial des clayes-sous-bois
le reportage d'astrid bergère et de
matteo luxe euros c'est la fin des
soldes les salles commerciales wang chen
paris outlet basée aux clayes-sous-bois
note un très bon bilan un bilan très
positif pour la raison c'est déjà emmené
à ciel ouvert donc notre clientèle est
tranquille pour venir faire son shopping
puisque la contamination est moindre
nous avions de beaux stocks
les résultats du mois de février sont
exceptionnelles puisque on progresse un
chiffre d'affaires de 68 %
donc on espère que ça va continuer ainsi
pour attirer les clients le centre a
proposé pendant ces six semaines des
remises supplémentaires aux réductions
déjà présentes
vous êtes sur 90 magasins avec une
tendance mode avec des belles des belles
enseignes qui ont proposé des remises
allant jusqu'à 70 % pendant les soldes
additionnel ou 30% du prix outlet donc
effectivement des très très bonnes
affaires sur des très belles marques
pour lapins pharmacie du centre
ouverte en octobre 2019 les soldats
présents dans les autres magasins ont
été bénéfiques
les soldes au niveau du centre nous
emploi avait tiré pas mal de clientèle
supplémentaire la parra quand même très
moteur pour le centre mais des ronds
travaillent conjointement justement avec
la direction pour que la fréquentation
facture en hausse les seuils de
maintenant fini le centre va quand même
continuer à proposer des offres
promotionnelles et des animations la
place ont à présent le curseur sur les
commerces de centre-ville quel bilan
dresses les commerçants locaux de la
période
comment s'adaptent ils aussi en cette
période de crise sanitaire nous recevons
en visioconférence est la pige à bonsoir
bonsoir merci membres
merci d'être avec nous est membre du
conseil d'administration de l'union des
commerçants et artisans de maurepas
l'association regroupe tous les
commerçants et tous les artisans du
centre ville mais aussi des différents
quartiers de la commune
déjà exclu d'une manière générale à la
période des soldes
disons plus généralement de la préfète a
été bonne pour les commerçants norvégien
alors pour les commerces
de bouche globalement plutôt plutôt
intéressante donc y en a on a foi ils
ont bien tiré leur épingle du jeu
globalement maintenant le confinement du
couvre-feu à partir de 18 heures brest
reste mitigé dans le sens où les
commerces ou des clients en fait n'ont
pas forcément le temps de faire leurs
courses avant 18h et du coup il ya un
manque à gagner et préfère regrouper
tous leurs achats et notamment dans dans
des centres commerciaux alimentaire
voilà un bilan plutôt bon malgré ce
couvre feu de 18h qui reste quand même
l'un on va dire l'un des points des
points négatifs
la tendance générale est présente depuis
longtemps vous parliez des centres
commerciaux est ce que la fermeture des
grands centres commerciaux a accentué
peut-être une tendance des clients à
revenir vers le commerce local où sap a
été observée au niveau de maurepas il
n'y a pas vraiment eu d'impact en fait
au niveau des commerçants de ne mord pas
le fait d'avoir fermé les grands centres
commerciaux
absolument aucun effet sur le petit
commerce de centre-ville
est ce que si on prend le curseur un peu
plus loin si on revient à l'origine de
cette crise sanitaire c'est à dire il ya
maintenant un an et ce que vous avez
l'impression quand même qui a une
habitude pour la clientèle maurepas
viennent de revenir vers vers du
commerce local
en tout cas est ce qu'il ya un retour
qui est observé sur le commerce local
vers le commerce local
non je dirais pas un retour mais plutôt
une découverte pour certaines personnes
c'est une découverte d'année
découvrir leurs commerces de proximité
il ya des gens qui n'allaient pas au con
qui n'arrive pas dans les commerces de
proximité et se sont rendus compte
qu'ils avaient des bons commerces avec
du service associé avec et est donc on
espère qu'après le lac au vide bas cet
état d'esprit continue et comment ont
distillé les commerçants maurepas bien
d'une manière générale cette crise
sanitaire on imagine bas à l'image de
tous de tout le monde finalement qu'il
ya une période d'adaptation qui a été
mise en place au début et peut-être que
depuis l'adaptation à puce se mettre en
place comment vit-il cette crise
sanitaire
alors pour certains pour certains c'est
ils la vivent très bien en fait fait bac
ils ont su s'adapter ils ont su
découvrent ils ont su s'adapter à une
nouvelle façon de travailler puisque en
fait c'est plus concentré sur sur la
journée avant les gens faisaient leurs
courses plutôt tardivement
maintenant c'est plus concentrés vers
la milieu de journée et donc c'est une
adaptation
certains commerçants moins bien donc ça
c'est pour les commerces de bouche c'est
beaucoup plus simple à s'adapter pour
certains commerces de type cordonnerie
aurait réparation de sacs etc
certaines certains commerces de vivre
plus mal dans le sens où ils ne savent
pas trop voir enfin il travaille au jour
le jour donc ya pas d y a pas d'effet de
vision long terme ce qui est plutôt
gênant pour un commerce dont on imagine
que les choses ne vont pas en
s'arrangeant alors on parle d'un
probable reconfirme ans les week-ends il
ya une inquiétude qui est qui est de
mise alors forcément il ya une grosse
inquiétude de mise du fait d'avoir
réalisé énormément peur d'un manque à
gagner notamment
peur de ne pas rattraper en fait les
samedis une dernière question on a vu
aussi des nouvelles solutions émergé
avec cette crise sanitaire celle du
drive du click and collect
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines avait d'ailleurs lancé son
application shopping sky pour mettre en
avant les commerces dans les 12 communes
de l'agglomération développer le drive
aussi est ce que les mots repas bien s'y
sont mis aussi au driver ont adhéré à
cette initiative chopine sky alors ne
drive effectivement il ya des magasins
de drague plutôt sur poignet magasin
drive sur nos repas effectivement le
phénomène de faire ses courses auchan
drive bon bah c'est clair c'est
indéniable c'est facile après il ya une
application click and collect leur tour
de clic and connect est très très mitigé
pour le moment donc veiller mort d'asia
ne se sont pas mis encore donc je pense
que il ya la mort basse et une c'est une
clientèle assez âgées et le fait
d'utiliser des applications internet me
paraît trop compliqué pour pour les
clients merci à les accuser d'avoir été
avec nous je rappelle que vous êtes
membre du conseil d'administration de
l'union des commerçants et des artisans
de maurepas et justement puisqu'on parle
des commerces direction chevreuse à
présent ce mardi matin le président du
conseil départemental des yvelines
pierre bédier venu rencontrer des
commerçants
ces derniers ont bénéficié d'une aide
d'urgence pour faire face à la crise la
crise économique miquel et demi d'euros
pierre bédier au chevet des commerçants
de cheuvreux ce mardi 2 mars le
président du département s'est rendu
dans plusieurs boutiques
il a vérifié à cette occasion la mise en
place d'un dispositif des d'urgence
votée par les yvelines pour faire face à
la crise sanitaire près de 18 millions
d'euros ont été débloqués pour les
commerces du département depuis juin
2020 normalement
nous sommes pas habilités à apporter des
aides économiques directs donc nous le
faisons en passant par les mairies qui
elles peuvent le faire et nous le
faisons parce que nous sommes le
département de la solidarité
enfin le l'institution de la solidarité
solidarité individuelle le département
gère les aides sociales mais solidarité
territoriale aussi c'est à dire le
département essaye d'aider toutes les
communes et chevron onze établissements
bénéficient de ce dispositif dans des
restaurants des cafés ou encore des
métiers liés à l'événementiel le
département rembourse le loyer avec un
certain plafond on rembourse une partie
des emprunts
cette boutique ouverte depuis mai 2000
20 aurait pu fermer ses portes sans
cette aide n'a jamais eu l'occasion
d'ouvrir la boutique
donc du coup on n'a jamais eu de
retombées financières et même si à côté
de cette activité on a un atelier
d'ébénisterie et ça permet pas de
couvrir l'intégralité des charges de la
boutique donc sans aide on aurait
probablement déjà fermée au total 48
1500 euros ont été refinancés par le
département à la commune de chevreuse
les commerçants chevreuse en ont besoin
je pense que votre malheureusement vous
voyez surtout le dispositif un
commerçant n'a pas pu n'a pas pu faire
faire face et a dû fermer mais
aujourd'hui on a rencontré une dizaine
de commerçants pour eux je pense qu'ils
l'ont ils l'ont dit ils l'ont rappelé
c'est vraiment quelque chose qui leur a
permis de traverser cette période le
département continuera à aider les
commerces dans les prochains mois
jusqu'à la fin de la crise sanitaire
dans les yvelines plus de 14 mille 600
commerces sont actuellement éligibles à
ce dispositif
au chapitre politique les élections
régionales qui doivent se dérouler les
13 et 20 juin prochains en ile de france
le nom du candidat qui va conduire la
liste du rassemblement national est
connu il s'agit de jordan bardella est
numéro deux du parti originaire de seine
saint denis l'avait mené la candidature
est reine aux dernières élections
européennes où la formation était arrivé
en tête lors des dernières régionales le
parti s'était classé en revanche
troisième avec 14 02 % des voix pour
cette campagne qui devrait porter autour
des transports des lycées de la sécurité
jordan bardel affirme vouloir rassembler
et au delà du rassemblement national
avec deux bouts la france notamment
dans les yvelines la liste de candidats
n'est pas encore arrêtée écoute et
d'ailleurs est la réaction du
responsable départemental du
rassemblement national pour nous c'est
évidemment le meilleur candidat possible
pour pour cette campagne pour la région
il a bien entendu mon total soutien
toute la fédération des yvelines un du
rassemblement national et à sa
disposition ils sont tous très
enthousiastes à l'idée de l'accompagner
dans cette campagne il a prouvé je crois
lors des élections européennes en tant
que tête de liste qui l'a amené à la
victoire
notre mouvement puisque nous sommes
arrivés en tête à l'échelon national
dans les yvelines par exemple nous
sommes arrivés en tête dans de très
nombreuses communes
donc je crois qu'effectivement il y a
une véritable adhésion autour de son
profil je crois qu'il a il a un profil
qui permet de rassembler là un profil
qui permet aussi de d'exprimer une
compétence sur un certain nombre de
sujets il est député européen et je
crois que sa cote de popularité ne cesse
de monter d'autres candidats se sont
déjà déclarés laurent saint martin pour
la république en marche julien bayou
avec europe ecologie les verts
audrey pulvar pour le parti socialiste
clémentine autain avec la france
insoumise est la présidente sortante
valérie pécresse devrait également être
en lice pour un nouveau mandat mais n'a
pas fait encore pour leur annonce
officielle
il est dit pour la troisième année
consécutive la clinique des
franciscaines à versailles s'est classée
première du à palmarès des hôpitaux et
cliniques établies par le journal le
point est dans la spécialité et
chirurgie du dos cette unité composée de
sept chirurgiens et le centre francilien
1 du dos a été créé en 2010 nicolas
landry vous le fait découvrir attention
certaines images peuvent heurter la
sensibilité des téléspectateurs
il est 10 heures à la clinique des
franciscaines de versailles le
neurochirurgien jean-françois le peintre
cofondateur du centre francilien du dow
vient de terminer une intervention
chirurgicale
un patient souffrant
do un patient qui avait une instabilité
vertébrale avec ce qu'on appelle un
spondylolisthésis et qui veut dire
qu'ils un glissement entre deux
vertèbres la troisième vertèbre était
instable sur la quatrième vertèbre qu'on
a stabilisé derrière et qu'on a enlevé
ce disque qui faisait partie
d'instabilité et qu'on a remplacé par un
implant qui va stabiliser ensemble en
créant un pont ou ceux entre les deux
vertèbres en fait le système devant ici
qui est celui qu'on a mis en place la
troisième lambert la quatrième revers à
la cinquième lombaire
le patient est arrivé le matin et repart
le soir même du centre hospitalier
l'opération se déroule sous anesthésie
générale plusieurs outils technologiques
sont utilisés objectif faciliter le
travail du chirurgien voir mais dans
cette machine qui va être positionné au
dessus et autour du patient et qui
robotisé pour regagner des positions de
travail qui sont programmées en début
d'intervention qui nous sert finalement
acquérir en trois dimensions là
les images
en position opératoire de la colonne
vertébrale du patient ce système de
navigation il va nous permettre
de travailler en temps réel avec un
repérage tridimensionnel sur la colonne
vertébrale du patient sans avoir besoin
d'une grande ouverture et en étant
beaucoup moins agressif puisque comme on
ouvre - on a moins de douleurs
postopératoires on a beaucoup moins de
saignements de risque de saignement
beaucoup beaucoup moins de risques
d'infections plusieurs outils sont
connectés à un système de navigation les
manipulations sont visibles directement
sur l'écran objectif retirer le disque
pathologique pour permettre
l'installation de l'implant entre deux
vertèbres
on doit calibre et tout ça pour remettre
le bon un plan donc là on a un fantôme
de 12 mm de haut de 55 mm de londres ça
va nous donner le gabarit de l'implant
définitif qu'on va mettre en place
créée en 2010 le centre francilien du
dos est composé de sept chirurgiens une
équipe complémentaire pour intervenir
sur l'ensemble de la colonne vertébrale
à travers différentes chirurgie c'est au
ce et neurologique en fait hein ça
concerne la colonne vertébrale
cervicales
thoracique aussi même si c'est moins
fréquent est beaucoup moins de problèmes
anthracite et puis lombaires ou c'est
fréquent des choses simples que tout le
monde connaît comme les initiales par
exemple aux choses un peu plus complexe
avec deux des problèmes d'arthrose
stabilité les
les fractures les traumatismes les
tumeurs de vertèbres pour la troisième
année consécutive le centre francilien
du dos a obtenu la première place du
palmarès des hôpitaux et des cliniques
catégorie chirurgie du dos un classement
publié dans le magazine du point dans
l'actualité également la situation
tendue à xp au logistique ce attrape
d'après les syndicats environ 60 des 81
salariés de la plate forme de
distribution alimentaires sont en grève
depuis vendredi dernier le site
trappistes du groupe de logistique et de
transport livre les hypermarchés auchan
en ile-de-france est les personnes
mobilisées dénonce de mauvaises
conditions de travail sur place trop de
pression harcèlement moral et mauvais
management et de la part du directeur
d'exploitation dont les syndicats
demandent le départ immédiat et les
représentants a été reçue récemment par
le directeur des ressources humaines en
ile de france
ils ont indiqué qu'ils ne reprendraient
pas le travail tant que le départ ne
serait pas acté
écoutez ses propos au micro de patrick
jacques de dixmude on a fait intervenir
vers un cabinet d'experts concernant les
risques psychosociaux que ça a été
demandé par l'inspection travail et par
le médecin travaille aussi
malgré tout ça en fait la direction elle
fait des trucs mais dit rich miner mais
tout le monde est dehors c'est pour le
départ comme si bien marquer là-bas en
fait le départ immédiat de directeur
d'exploitation après on discute sur les
espoirs qui sont sur leurs
revendications
aujourd'hui tout le monde vivait là
c'est sûr ça s'il n'y a pas ce point-là
6 rien n'est ce pas en fait tu aura pas
de reprise de travail
mais joint par notre rédaction le siège
dicks théologie stx nous a répondu par
une déclaration avant de pouvoir prendre
des mesures je cite nécessaire la
direction indique vouloir favoriser le
dialogue de proximité et comprendre les
différentes revendications
il a fermé ses portes hier pour un mois
le zooparc 2 3 ris ne rouvrira pas avant
le 2 avril au moins décisions prises en
prévision d'un possible reconfirme ans
les week-ends en ile-de-france jour où
le site reçoit beaucoup de public est
resté ouvert ne serait pas rentable pour
le lieu qui a perdu environ cent mille
visiteurs en un an le mois de fermeture
va permettre d'assurer des tâches de
logistique et d'effectuer des travaux de
maintenance
avant de refermer ce journal focus sur
le musée maurice denis à saint germain
elle vient de prêter une oeuvre à une
exposition en amérique aux états unis le
musée est habitué à ce genre de prêt à
travers le monde
explications dans ce sujet d'astrid
bergère et d'eléonore sinoquet le chemin
dans les arbres les cinq femmes au
tombeau ou encore la maternité de mersin
c'est toi qui appartiennent au musée
maurice denis à saint germain en laye
viennent d'être prêté la dernière est
parti aux états unis
on est sollicité l'un pour le prêt d'une
oeuvre qui s'appelle la maternité à
mersin qui est une oeuvre de maurice
denis une huile sur toile qui a été
peinte en 1896 1897 et donc en fait
c'est une coorganisation d'exposition
aux états unis entre les musées de
cleveland et le musée de portland
le musée maurice denis possède près de
5000 ces prêts sont assez courts entre
les différents établissements du monde
entier on passe une convention qui va
régir bien évidemment tout ce qui relève
à la fois des assurances bien évidemment
du transport de la sécurité et même du
climat dans lequel vont être exposées
les oeuvres et maurice denis à sa petite
notoriété à l'international
l'artiste qui est né à granville et qui
est mort à paris a vécu toute sa vie à
saint germain en laye dans les zones
hissé aussi bien indécis mettre sa
touche à tout en fait il est dessinateur
il est peintre il travaille aussi sur
des vitraux
il écrit énormément c'est c'est le
théoricien on dit du groupe des nabis
il a vécu quasiment toute sa vie à saint
germain en laye le musée est
actuellement fermés il doit rouvrir le
17 septembre 2021 avec une exposition
inaugurale qui vise à commémorer le 150e
anniversaire de maurice denis et les 40
ans du musée avant de vous laisser on a
appris il ya quelques minutes que la
préfecture des yvelines mettait en place
de nouvelles mesures pour faire face à
l'épidémie de kobe de 19
une des mesures annoncées c'est le port
du masque qui est désormais obligatoire
sur la voie publique et dans les lieux
ouverts au public
sur l'ensemble du territoire yvelinois
plusieurs et exception sauf pour les
personnes
de moins de 11 ans port du masque qui
n'est pas obligatoire dans les véhicules
particuliers et professionnels pour les
cyclistes pour les deux roues si la
visière du casque et baissé pour les
personnes handicapées avec justificatif
également pour les activités sportives
enfin être dernière et exception pour
les personnes seules ou pour les groupes
de six qui se promène en forêt enfin une
autre mesure qui a été annoncé au delà
de ce port du masque obligatoire c'est
l'interdiction de la consommation de
boissons alcoolisées sur la voie
publique ce sont des mesures que nous
pourrons développer dans deux prochaines
éditions
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci
de votre fidélité dans un instant
retrouvez l'émission de 7,8 culture
présentée par célia gars tsongo belle
soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]